I was thinking about a story from the
Bible I'm not a religious man but I've
read bits and pieces over the years
curiosity more than faith in this one
story there was a man he was traveling
from Jericho to Jerusalem when he was
set upon by men of ill intent they
stripped the traveler of his clothes
they beat him and they left him bleeding
in the dirt a priest happened by saw the
traveler and crossed to the other side
of the road and continued on next day
Lev aight a religious functionary came
to the place saw the dying traveler but
he to cross to the other side of the
road and passed him by but then came a
man from Samaria a Samaritan a good man
he saw the traveler bleeding in the road
and stopped to eat him without thinking
about the circumstances or the
difficulty it might bring him he tended
to the travelers wounds applying oil and
wine he carried him to an inn and gave
him all the money he had for the manager
to take care of the traveler
he did this simply because the man was
his neighbor he loved the city and all
the people in it I always thought I was
the Samaritan in that story hmm it's
funny isn't it hell even the best of men
are deceived by their own true nature I
am NOT disinherited I am NOT the priest
or they were the Levite I am the ill
intent who sit upon the traveler on a
road he should not have been on